like if 300-series is no good at all
what's the alternative
now what did you reach for your
calculator now now wait you got a
calculator there my other cousin can I
borrow someone's of okay so you've got
your on your calculator there right well
what I want you to do is if I can press
the right buttons at least let me carry
the the vast majority of you using I
want you to go shift and then hit this
setup button right it's loaded and set
up but if you go shift
it'll keep you set up okay and then a
series of options comes up now the
particular ones I want to Tory attention
to are options 3 4 and 5 3 4 and 5
ok now here are the three options that
we're particularly interested these are
three schemes for thinking about and
measuring angles right now the first one
you already know what that is and if the
one that you've already been using all
of these years
okay I will quickly tell you about that
last one on the list
option number five funnily enough it's
what I'm mainly what European engineers
use I teach you not that called radians
they were like 360 360 and so Imperial
right like do you see 60 like you know
12 12 feet in an inch that kind of thing
it's it's kind of also held over into
the imperial system where monitor we
want to use the metric system right so
therefore instead of 360 right which
makes a right angle of 90 degrees what
this particular group of people says 90
we're so close to an awesome metric
number namely a hundred why not make a
hundred the size of the angle
arriving because right angles are the
most important being goes to c13
engineers so if you've got a hundred
units around into a right angle how many
of how many of them are in a revolution
and to four hundred okay now those are
those units are called gray years right
and we never used them so please never
ever put your calculator in that way
maybe they might make things more
convenient for measurement but they do
not make the mathematics anymore it
doesn't make any of the interesting
mathematics more accessible like finer
degrees it I suppose so you then again
you know that argument fails when you
can say well I think just to buy Oh fair
enough
and which we do in two degrees but it's
a second okay now the particular option
that I am interested is option four
radians now radians are bad and I will
try and convince you why let me try and
explain what radians are you can clearly
see from what's going on here in your
head I hope you can see that angles and
rotation kind of imply circles right
they kind of imply circles rotation is
really about circles
okay so radians you subway radians are a
measure of angles that are defined by
circles radians are a measure of angles
that are defined by circles okay
so draw for me draw for me I am a circle
underneath where you've written is okay
it doesn't have to be too huge we're not
gonna have very complicated M diagram on
here what's your mark in the set up
now for simplicity sake what we're gonna
do is we're just gonna start thinking
about the unit circle I'm just going to
start thinking about the unit circle as
you'll see and one of the reasons why
this is useful is that it generalizes
past be in a circle we don't just have
to be on the unit circle but it'll make
the numbers a little bit easier so I'm
going to define a Radian in terms of the
two important features of my circle
namely the radius and that's in fact
where radians come from though the word
and the circumference okay
so you remember we said okay 360 degrees
is a revolution okay so my question is
well how many radians should there be in
a circle right that's like my equivalent
of how FAR's are taking to go all the
way around now this is the unit circle
this is the intercept good one what is
the circumference of this it's two PI R
but being the unit circle R is one okay
so therefore the circumference of this
whole circle is 2 pi 2 pi you UK with
that so therefore what I do as I say
okay
the angle to go all the way around the
circle use a better color be able to go
all the way around the circle is 2 pi
right this angle will give me the entire
length of the circumference right which
in the circumference is 2 pi so
therefore I'll call that angle the whole
revolution I will call it to 5 okay now
once you define that M rather than cloud
this diagram I'm gonna let's draw some
other smaller circles beside you okay
once you have that do you have all these
other conversions you can make for
instance you got a circle here if I say
all right
here's a radius and if I don't to go all
the way around the circle if for
instance I want to go half way
once I go halfway around the circle
what's the length of the arc that's been
traced out by that link what's the
length of this and the answer is it's
half of the of the circumference which
is not 2 pi but PI right so I call this
angle PI now probably I can fit it on to
this diagram as well if I use a
different color if I did not want to go
halfway around the circle let's say Oh a
quarter of the way around the circuit
because you know maybe that size is kind
of a useful number right or 1/4 the
right amount of second would apply to
videos and I would indicate it with a
right angle because that's what a
quarter of a second is is my name right
now a quarter the way around is a
quarter of two pi and a quarter of two
pi is ply on - ok now I can keep going
right if I define for myself that 2 pi
equals 360 degrees that's all the way
around the circle my angle
and if I say okay pi is 180 degrees and
PI on 2 equals 90 degrees then I could
take all the angles that I'm familiar
with all those combinations and I can
come up with their equivalent in radians
right so for instance let's think about
how about 360 over 180 I've got 90 let's
think about all those angles there are
three of them morning that have an exact
value for the trig ratios right like
sine cousin tan of these three angles
I'll get nice like happy thirds other
one decimal right okay so if you what
are the up what are the three angles
that I'm interested
I'm gonna go 45 what's another one 30
and 60 okay now let's just do all of
these quickly in turn of being that I
already have plans - yeah it's easy to
get to 490 grace to 45 degrees because I
have it right safe plan - is 90 degrees
then PI on 4 is 4
five degrees you very that I've just
halved it again it's gonna move this up
so I have spaced now five 180 degrees
and that's pi radians then how do I get
to sixty I divide by three good so they
said a PI it's just final three and my
last one down here do you get from 60 to
30 I'm gonna hop back to that classics
okay now obviously there are more values
I mean there's any first set of values
but those are your important ones right
just like you got used to saying sign
thirties a half like you almost don't
even need to think that anymore it's
just it's just in there you're going to
not need to start to use these as much
as you can and when you see PI on six do
you think oh yeah that's that's why I go
30 greens when you see PI on to you like
yeah that's a right angle